pisa ping de diverses émissions télé et
variés petit pêle-mêle pot-pourri très
pourri amiez dit ma vie et mes plantes
grenelle s'y connaissent on sera tous
vendus dans des chiffres et des lettres
on est parti pour se faire chier pendant
une heure que je sais qu soir vous avez
l'habitude on va se faire chier avec
bertrand renard et ariane qui sont à la
base ça fait 35 ans qu'on s'emmerde ça
va pas changer aujourd'hui un bon deux
candidats semblent du s'emmerder avec
louis wattez qui doit conduire à témoin
que j'ai eu mon bac d'accord si j'ai pas
eu mon bac j'ai pas eue au mac do bumba
gelé par le back to stop des propos
pourquoi tous nos matches et maintenant
j'ai pas mon bac tu arrêtes de dire
aujourd'hui mon bac du néo gunner
bienvenue dans le mag on commence bien
sûr par le sujet brûlant la loi m
conneries vous en pensez quoi de cette
loi dans l'amour c'est pas là dessus le
décret 67 est une aberration c'est une
année l'attention dont attention la dcri
67 et pas ratifié par le sénat donc pas
conforme à la constitution vous le savez
ça c'est très clair c'est dans le code
civil venant à peut-être que vous
reposer votre côté ville attention un
robinson la cie négateurs universel il
prend pas au prorata de ses émoluments
et moi je m'en fous